he lets the house fix cause our man
Montes karad visited the last major car
show of the year the los angeles auto
show the US market and especially the
California market he says are key for
automakers around the world so not
surprisingly there were 30 global debuts
and Tony North American premieres it was
a challenge to see them all in my
spanish not America premiere on
superstar and avocado Shaffer vehicle I
things money the los angeles auto show
is designed more for the general public
rather than for the experts of the
automotive world it always draws
thousands of car enthusiasts BMWs M for
GTS made its north american debut it's
the group second most expensive model in
the US and it caused quite a stir BMW's
Hildegard board one says if anyone
thought cars had lost their emotional
appeal they just need to watch visitors
looking at the m4 GTS Porsche also had
plenty to pump up the adrenaline
unveiling two new models first the
Cayman gt4 clubsport the 283 kilowatt
mid-engine supercar is designed for club
and amateur racing and is not certified
for public roads sales started
immediately after unveiling also making
its international debut was the revamp
Porsche 911 targa pulses Porsche stands
for a certain kind of lifestyle a
lifestyle that suits California says
Porsches North America CEO Klaus selmer
indulgence great design innovation all
these things go well with California and
the 911 and especially the target
incorporates all these things in Spencer
modem Targa oh come on ecosystem
like the Carrera 4 & 4s the new target
models have a more compact twin-turbo
engine which replaces the naturally
aspirated motors there are also subtle
changes to the exterior fiat has revived
its 124 spider with a new model based on
the Mazda mx-5 and Kia unveiled its new
Sportage
so I spin yet montes has now left the
show ground for a short while to step
out into the beautiful November weather
of LA and take a spin he's going to try
out volkswagen's new electric golf the
next model for the American market then
ego if this next model Yaga's couldn't
USMLE Concha marked from folks loading
the car moves off almost without a sound
Ryan toxic Mayan Montes says one battery
charge will take you 83 miles that's 140
to 150 kilometers and that's pretty good
but the best thing about this cars and
VW doesn't have to worry about emissions
that was the overriding subject at the
VW press conference in LA not
surprisingly us a buzz mikio horn
promise to do everything necessary to
win back customers confidence the CEO of
volkswagen group of america i can tell
you nothing is more important to me
personally than they set a section of
our customers into making things right
with all those who have put their faith
and trust and works like over the years
VW unveiled the new beetle dune a street
car with an off-road exterior it's a
cool throwback to the Baja Bug complete
with chunky rear spoiler and aluminum
skid plates inside the beetle dune comes
with sporty-er seats featuring optional
contrasting stitching as well as a
leather-wrapped steering wheel the dune
will be available both as a coupe a and
a convertible
and another convertible made its global
bow in LA the range rover evoque
infinity unveiled a QX 30 crossover
based on the Mercedes GLA Mercedes
presented the GLS as Cabrillo and SL
roadster Lamborghini was not at the show
but unveiled the hurricane LP 582 at a
private event in LA the rear-wheel drive
version of the hugely popular Heric on
offers 426 kilowatts of power
the segment Lamborghini CEO stephan
winkelmann says more than fifty percent
of the super sports car segment features
real wheel drive vehicles and
Lamborghini wants to serve this market
although the company's unique selling
proposition is all-wheel drive
Lamborghini still wants to continue to
market its two-wheel drive version
between Daka Toyota paid homage to the
back of the future movies showing off a
modified me right fuel cell vehicle
complete with a mr. fusion power plant
and fake flux capacitor but it wasn't
all just science fiction toyota also
presented the 4th generation prius 90
kilowatts of system power output allow
the hybrid to go from zero to 100
kilometers in ten point six seconds the
Prius is the first model based on
Toyotas new global architecture it's
been totally redesigned and the driving
experience has been greatly improved
escaped oh I didn't father mother says
there's one type of vehicle that is
simply a must in the US and therefore an
American auto shows and that's the
pickup truck a petite vehicle that could
surely be squeezed into any parking
space not hot him on the lights huh
anyone got a ladder so [ __ ] of the
Roman it makes you wonder why the
Japanese build such small cars he says
this would fit between any cars or even
over the top under the hood a mere 8
cylinder 6.4 liter engine with just 410
horsepower he had to look up the fuel
consumption online as he couldn't find
it anywhere here he found that it uses
an average 17 liters for 100 kilometers
which he doesn't quite believe he thinks
if cars like this can be licensed in the
US and what's all the fuss about the
diesel emissions scandal